hi everyone
um yeah thanks for the introduction
um yeah it's as announced I'm talking
about root cause and is with Dwight wise
and open source library for causal
inference tasks
um
in Python of course and um yeah today I
want to talk about this particular set
of features that we introduced there
last year so the talk has roughly four
sections first I will talk about do I
what what is it what can you do with it
um then I will talk about some
hypothetical example you could solve
with it and then I will dive deeper into
a particular example so I will go
through notebook and show you step by
step how you could solve a particular
root cause problem and then at the end I
want to zoom out a bit and talk about Pi
y Pi wise and independent ecosystem for
causal learn packages on GitHub and yeah
hope to make some advertisement for that
so first of all what can you do with the
Y so do I was initially developed by
Microsoft with the main focus on effect
estimation tasks and um yeah in the
meantime we also developed an um causal
library at AWS
using a so-called graphical causal
models which nicely complement the
feature set of DUI and so accordingly we
started the collaboration with Microsoft
to open source our library in in Dubai
and extended features that accordingly
that was roughly last year in May and
since then Dubai is also now an
independent package so it doesn't belong
to Microsoft or AWS it's it's
independent now
um and in this talk I want to mostly
focus on the graphical causal model part
and what you can do with this
um but before here's a rough overview of
what you can do with with Dubai so on
the left side you see some some causal
questions you have so you see effect
estimation tasks you can do what if
analysis you can do root cause analysis
and explanations the main part of this
talk and what you also see is what kind
of yeah model tabs you need so you need
for most of them you need a causal graph
that models your causal directions
um and for some other tasks you need
also to model so-called causal
mechanisms which I will also introduce
later but let's first look at a typical
effect estimation example
so here you see an online shop and I
guess you know which online show I'm
using here so it's a Amazon shop where
you have a product and yeah I guess it's
a bit small here but you see two buttons
here on the right the add to basket and
the buy no button
and now the question is what happens if
we change the color of the by no button
would more people click on it
so basically what we want to do
ultimately is we want to increase the
revenue by people clicking on the buy
now button and by the way for people who
don't know what what the buy note button
does it skips like all the
checkout process and it goes straight to
the to the you just confirm it and the
articles article is already sent to you
and another question is okay if we would
change it from this kind of orange to
this more red color would more people
click on it
um and ultimately the question is would
the revenue increase what you would
typically do in practice is you do an A
B testing right you show like 50 of
customers the orange button 50 the more
red button and and in the end you
compare the revenue but that takes time
um you might lose money if if the button
for instance is white maybe no one even
sees it so can you do that maybe
statistically using something like do I
and of course that's possible so
basically all you need to do is you um
so yes there's a small example so you
you define your choreograph which
basically models the relationships you
believe
um between your variables and your data
you define your treatment variable in
this case button color which you want to
change and then you can plug this in
into an estimator and here for instance
we use economl which is another
third-party Library which is focusing on
effect estimation tasks so this already
should show you we support third-party
packages and heavily want to utilize
that then you you fit that estimate and
you estimate your effect and then fully
data driven you can estimate the impact
of changing the color without actually
performing the experiments in in real
life
of course under strong assumptions
um
so that is the effect estimation part
now the next part I want to mainly focus
on is this part down here
so
um when you when you look at this
graphic you see that there are two two
components to this one first you need
your causal graph and secondly you also
need the causal mechanisms and if you
have both together this is what we call
graphical causal models and this allows
you to do a lot of fancy things
um so first of all what are graphical
causal models so yeah as I said there
are two parts the first one is the grass
structure where you believe
um or what you believe are the cause of
relationships in your data and the
interpretation I think it's it's fairly
easy so like this node is a parent node
for instance of this one and this just
means this is the cause and this is the
effect and this is how you define it
and since I already know this question
will come up um so this graph you can
for instance derive it from from data if
you don't know how to to construct the
graph in the first place
um also it's not not that robust if you
do it from data or you can use domain
knowledge so for instance there are many
ways to actually know the relationships
of certain components in your system
and the second part of of this is
modeling the yeah the so-called causal
mechanism so when you look at this graph
you can model it as a causal Bayesian
Network and
um this basically composes into
um so you model The Joint distribution
of the data here and the nice property
of Bayesian networks is you can
decompose it into conditionals of of a
node given its parents
um and here we are particularly
interested in causal Bayesian networks
not just Bayesian networks so the
difference here is the cost-based
networks basically has one one ground
truth the true causal directions while
Bayesian Networks you're actually happy
with anything coming from an active and
lens class or there are multiple
Solutions but not all of them are causal
um what we're particularly doing into Y
is we use so-called functional causal
models
um
which you can simply think of each node
can be described by a function which
takes as an input is parents and some
some noise the noise is assumed to be
not observed and is the most crucial
part here because
um by by having this functional form
here you can do all kinds of things like
estimating pointwise counterfactuals
um for certain outcomes That You observe
which for instance are not possible if
you just have a patient Network where
where the notion of noise in that form
doesn't even exist
so I guess the yeah the takeaway is the
the goal of the graphical causal model
is to model the data generation process
okay so when you when you have these
graphical causal models what can you do
with it you can do things like root
cause analysis in complex systems um you
can do attribution of distribution
change to Upstream nodes
um you can do you can quantify causal
influences so when you have like these
these graphs you can quantify how strong
are the causal connections directly but
also like indirectly and you can of
course do things like point-wise
contextuals for particular observations
and for all these things you will see
some more concrete examples
um
so you can apply now all these things
with a few line of codes with DUI so
here what we are doing is we basically
just import the GCM module from Dubai we
Define a so-called structural causal
model here
and then the way how you define the
graph is fairly simple you use for
instance Network X I guess Network X is
like the biggest graph library in in
Python where you just say for instance
here x is the cause of Y and Y is the
cause of of that and this just defines
your your chain for instance so this is
already the step up here where you find
the graph and then the next step is you
have to define the functional causal
models here
and you can either do that manually when
you have domain knowledge or you know
you want to use particular models or you
can ask the why to do this automatically
so you just say you just use the auto
module you call the assign call the
mechanisms plug in your your model and
the data and then use some heuristic to
assign these models automatically so
it's basically the step here and then
afterwards you fit the the model on the
data so under the hood it just goes over
all the mechanism fits it and then
you're ready to use it and as you see
here we are mostly following a
functional approach so instead of saying
scm.fit we say fit and then put the GCM
the SCM object in there
there are some reasons to it but I um
yeah it probably takes too much time to
explain
um
but I guess the message is after you fit
the model you're ready to use it and
afterwards it will not be modified
anymore so you can always reuse the same
object for different causal tasks
okay so here's a more concrete example
what we can do
so imagine you have an on-hand inventory
planning system and that consists of
many uh many steps so for instance you
have a demand forecast like how will my
demand be next week
um you have some some simulation maybe
um how will be the economic situation
over the next week and this together
defines your planning then there's the
bidding on your on your product and all
these things together then finally
defines the amount of inventory you have
at the end
and let's say we have the following
situation
we see here on the right that um in 2019
we have an online inventory about
roughly zero percent or above zero
percent this is this is what we want
right we don't want to too much
inventory here and we don't want to fuel
inventory but now suddenly in 2020 what
we observe is that there is a sudden
drop so over over these weeks it dropped
by 20 percent
I know we wonder why did the drop What
What In Our planning system change that
it suddenly dropped why is it not
accurate anymore and you can figure this
out with an easy function call from from
Dubai where you just plug in your causal
model you define your target node
um some other parameters and then it
gives you like a contribution to all the
Upstream nodes
um how much it contributed to this
change in your data
another example the main example will go
through the notebook as well is root
cause analysis in cloud services so here
we have Amazon cloudfront like just
think of it as a front-end for the users
and in the background there's a lot of
different processes happening so there's
a Gateway there's a AWS Lambda function
which accesses a dynamodb and so on
and now what happens is we might observe
some Peak and latency in our front end
so here for instance okay it's super
small but maybe you see some Peaks here
and we want to explain why why we have
these Peaks where do they come from and
you can imagine like the dynamodb maybe
has some some high latency which causes
a high latency in the Lambda which cause
a high latency in the gate Gateway and
so on so there's like a chain effect of
these of these anomalies and basically
automatically one identify okay which
which of these components is responsible
for this peak and
um here in particular we're interested
in the P99 latency for instance which is
this small thing down here and again you
can do this easily with um
with a function called to do y you just
plug in your causal model you specify
your target node here this would be the
cloud front
and you put also in the concrete sample
here that you're interested in and it
gives you the attribution to all all the
Upstream notes Here in the
in the graph and what you can do in
addition you can also simulate
interventions so now you identified
maybe the the root cause you can ask the
question okay what if I would reduce the
latency would this fix my issue and you
can simulate this by doing a so-called
intervention and Sample new latencies
from a hypothetical distribution where
you where you fixed your issue and see
if that actually helped you in reducing
the latency okay now we'll switch over
to to notebook to take a look at this a
bit more in detail
I hope that's okay in the back to read
okay so the example we have here is um
example in microservices
so here we are particularly modeling the
checkout process of our website so when
you go to an online store you place an
order then it takes some time until the
order is confirmed or something went
wrong and got rejected or something and
basically what happens is as soon as you
click on the button a stuff of
um the place when you click on the place
order button a lot of stuff happened in
the background so here's like a overview
of a dependency graph so you have you
have this website node which is the
website you are interacting with when
you when you click on place order it
access like a web service which acts as
like an API which accesses in product
service and so on like like this a whole
bunch of stuff happening in the
background
I know
um
imagine this one are normally happening
somewhere and the user suddenly face a
high latency then you want to identify
which of these nodes is responsible for
this
um by the way this graph is uh
artificially generated and also the data
I'm using so it's based on on real
architectures of course we we saw and
most of the data is try to mimic real
data but the yeah just as a disclaimer
these are all artificial data things
here
um so the first thing we would do is we
load in some data
and here um for instance we just use
pandas
um load in the CSV but where the data
comes from it doesn't matter as long as
it's a data frame in the end and the
format is I think quite quite normal so
you have your tabular data format where
the columns correspond to certain nodes
in your graph
so these are just the node names and
each of these values here represents
some latency in in seconds
um so like pretty normal normal format
here and the first thing we do when we
want to model this is we take a look at
the data how does the data look like so
here's some some scatter plot and um
yeah it's I guess again too small but
yeah so yeah some Scatter Plots and by
the way the step is also optional so if
you if you don't want to look it's get
uploads you don't necessarily need to do
that
um so what you see is on the on the
diagonal you see like the um yeah
so-called marginal distributions of the
node so like if you just take a look at
the date of each node individually you
would get this kind of of distribution
and what you already see here is first
of all you don't have negative latencies
which is I think quite quite clear and
you also see that you have these rather
um yeah half half normal distribution so
you have
um
like a lot of latencies which are quite
fast and then you also have some
latencies that that take a bit longer so
you have like a long tail distribution
here and there's already some some good
information we could use later for
modeling this graph
um then when you take a look at these
pairwise plots
um you also get some some useful
information so many of these plots can
be described by a simple linear function
so
um I guess the most obvious one is down
here the web service and the the website
you see this is like a very
linear function with with some noise so
linear function would probably already
be a good good description of this and
similar for the other one as well
although it's quite quite large noise of
course but you also have some more
complicated things like here the caching
service and product DB where like a
normal linear function would not be a
good fit or you probably couldn't even
model this accurate at all
um okay so this these are already some
some helpful information
so now the first thing we will do is we
will set up the the causal graph the
causal Dynamic directions and here we're
using um as I mentioned earlier Network
X and we import the GCM module and
simply Define the graph no one thing
um when we think about the causal
relationships of latencies when we take
a look at this late at the dependency
graph then it's quite clear that a high
latency for instance in the product DB
would cause a high latency in the
caching service and not the other way
around
so the caching service would need to
wait for the product to be and not the
product DB needs to wait for the caching
service at least in this simplified
setting of course there are more
complicated ones therefore when you
think of the causal directions we
actually need to flip the edges here so
the dependency graph just flip the edges
and this is exactly how we Define it
here so the web services course of of
website and the authentication Services
the course of the web service and so on
and when we do this and plot it then we
get exactly the dependency graph just
with the flipped flipped arrows
okay so this was already the part of
defining the causal causal graph now we
need to define the causal mechanisms and
here we can now make use of the
knowledge we got from the Scatter Plots
so the first thing we do is we Define
our causal model here
it's a structural causal model then we
iterate over the nodes and then as soon
as we have a root node we basically
assign a distribution so here in this
case we use siphy for instance and in
particular we use the sci Pi half normal
distribution because we saw earlier in
the Scatter Plots half normal
distribution seems to be a good fit and
as you also see here we use scipy right
so you can plug in any any sci-fi
distribution you don't need to be
dependent on whatever the Y has
implemented of course we have some
wrapper function to make sure that it
works with the rest of the library but
here you can just plug in any any Cipher
distribution
um and then in the else part here this
is when we when we don't have a root
node we need to Define these functional
causal models and what we are
particularly doing here is we use
so-called additive noise models
over here and the additive nose models
you see here on the right is basically
something like this you have y equals f
of x plus n and the X here are the
parents
um and the F here is some kind of
function that can be arbitrary and in
our case we particularly use a linear
regression function and again here we
use scikit-learn so you can plug in any
cycle circuit learn regression model
random Forest neural network whatever
you want and
um yeah that's all that's all you need
to do so you define your causal
mechanisms
and now you might think okay I don't
want to iterate over this I don't want
to think about all these models you can
alternatively also just call the auto
module and ask do I to do this
automatically so you just say assign
causal mechanisms put idiom model put in
the data which it should be based on and
then it will go over your data and
assign these models completely automatic
so you don't have to think too much
about it but if you if you have some
knowledge it's probably better to do it
manually
then afterwards you are ready to fit the
models so you just call fit then this
the scroll model gets fit if it's fitted
and then um it's it's good to go and the
first scenario we are looking at is um
so let's say you're you're an on-call
operator and suddenly a customer
complains hey the the checkout process
takes so long
um what what is going on there so what
what happens what we do now is we take a
look at this particular trace for uh for
the um for the customer
um which we load in here so you see it's
really just one line of a of a penis
data frame with one particular set of
observation for each node and of course
the first thing we do is is it really
slower
then what we normally expect from the
data and here we see okay indeed it's
two seconds slower than on average
um okay it's maybe not super much slower
but it's it's a bit slower and now we
want to identify okay why why is it
slower which of these parts are
responsible for that
and um this for this we can now use the
GCM attribute a normal dysfunction so we
just plug in our causal model we say
okay we're interested in the website
node
and then we also specify the sample we
want to analyze so in this case our
outlier data that we just
um that we just loaded and this gives us
a dictionary with all the attributions
and yeah to make the plot or to make the
interpretation a bit easier we can plot
it let me zoom in
um where we now get a nice overview of
all the attributions so you see for
instance that the caching service has
acquired quite large attribution to the
contribution to the outliers that we
observed or the the order service I saw
also some slide attribution score and
also the product service on the other
end what we also see is we have a
negative attribution score here which
can be interpreted that this in in this
case a customer idb for instance was
particularly fast so it reduces the
likelihood of having an anomaly here
which is also some some valuable
information but since we're interested
in root causing the the anomaly we will
probably only look at the positive ones
and regarding the interpretation of
these scores it's a bit bit more complex
um if you're interested in we can maybe
talk about this afterwards but just
think of it the the higher the more
severe
okay and maybe also a big small spoiler
alert since we generated this data
artificially the the caching Services
here the true root cause so this this
behaves a bit slower than than usual
um okay so what what we did know is we
plugged in a single observation based on
our trained model and it told us exactly
how much each of the Upstream nodes
contributed to this anomaly which I
think is already some super good
information to
um yeah debug your system
okay so now this was a single
single single operation that we did we
trained one model we did one run of this
attribute a normally score function but
we maybe want some confidence interval
of this right so it could be that every
time you fit the models they they
slightly get different parameters also
the attribute anomalies is not not
deterministic it's a stochastic function
so you might get slightly different
results every time so what you can also
do is you can estimate a confidence
interval where we have a simple simple
wrapper for that you just say confidence
interval you also specify that you want
to fit and recompute the graph every
time and then you just plug in your your
parameters here at this at this point
and you repeat that you want to repeat
that whole thing 10 times
and then what we get is we get this
overview with with the confidence bars
which are very similar to the previous
one but now you see for instance that
this product service has has bit higher
uncertainty although it's still still
quite small
okay so this is for analyzing a single
single anomaly event that we had now
let's say this this issue with the um
with the higher with the high latency is
persistent and uh we still don't know
what is actually what is actually going
on so to to check that a bit further we
can now say okay let's collect a bit
more data let's collect 1000 additional
requests so we load this in again
um simple penders data frame with with
1000 rows in this case and we're
interested in the website latency and
um again the sanity check we see okay
indeed this outlier data on average for
the website is two seconds lower
um now what what is going on which part
of our system is actually causing this
issue here
um and now we can make use of the
so-called distribution change measure
method
which takes the causal model it takes
the data how it looked when the system
would behave normal and it takes the
data how it the system would behave if
it's not normal so in our case the
slower slower data we specify the target
note we're interested in it's the
website and then we can also say the
quantity we want to attribute so here we
we are interested in the difference of
the means so we Define
um we can simply Define the C as the
difference between the two two means but
if you for instance interested in the
difference of the variance like the you
experience higher variants in your
latencies then you just change this to
to VAR and then you would do the
attribution with respect to the variance
um
so after this you get again a dictionary
with all your attributions and when you
plot this now you get a very clear
picture that the caching service here is
indeed the one that is actually causing
causing you issue in in this case and
you also see that there are some super
small
attributions for the other nodes which
in this case is for instance just some
some noise from the approximations and
to get rid of this you can again um do
like a confidence interval where you run
it 10 times in total and then you see um
they they yeah these small contributions
go away kind of
okay so now what we now did is we
collected more data we plugged it in the
distribution change method and it
pinpointed us exactly to the service
that caused caused this issue and when
you take a look at this graph this is
this is not obvious at all right so this
here here's the caching service
um which caused this High latency in the
website and um all we need to do is
collect the data throw it in and um we
already know it's a caching service
let's let's try to fix it
um and the last scenario I want to get
at is simulating the intervention
simulation of interventions so let's say
we know now it's it's a caching service
that is the issue but we maybe are not
able to directly uh fix it
but maybe what we can do is we can
mitigate the high latency in the
meantime and what we can do here for
instance is we can shift some Computing
Services from
um from the shipping cost service over
to the caching service but this comes
with some costs so we by by moving these
compute resources over we basically make
the shipping cost service slower but we
would speed up the caching service now
the question is does it actually help us
if we would do this and in this
particular example we assume that by
removing Computing resources from the
shipping cost service we make the
shipping cost service two seconds slower
but speed up the caching service by one
second so again two seconds slower
shipping or service one second
um faster caching service doesn't
actually help us
and we can simulate this now so we would
fit our model on the outlier data and
then we perform in
um we get some so-called Interventional
samples here and here we basically
simply specify okay the caching service
is now one second slower and the
shipping cost service is
um and no sorry the caching service is
one second faster and the shipping cost
service is two seconds slower so we add
two seconds to the shipping conserver
and remove one second from the caching
service now how would how would the
overall latency of our website look like
and when we plot the C and compare it we
see that before the the latency were
roughly 5.5 seconds and afterwards it's
yeah 4.5 seconds so we overall were able
to reduce the latency by one second and
we simulated this completely based on
the data we didn't do this in in in
practice yet at least but now we know
okay if we would do it we would reduce
the latency so we can go ahead and do
this until we mitigate the issue
okay so this was the the example I
wanted to show you
um now at the end I want to
um briefly zoom out and
um talk about Pi y
so Pi Y is an open source ecosystem for
machine learning libraries it's an
independent organization
um it's it's a GitHub organization you
can also go to the piway.org website
the mission statement yeah maybe I won't
read it out but the mission statement
basically says um
that that we try to have a collection of
Open Source causal inference libraries
that are interoperable are practical for
users and um also yeah improve the state
of the art for for causal inference
um it's we just founded it last year
around May so it's still in a very rough
shape there's there are a few libraries
but um the inter operable part is is not
not there yet at least
um he's he's like a rough overview of
different of different projects that we
have in there so we have we have Dubai
the the largest package we have do
discover and causal learn which are
focusing on on causal inference based on
on data for instance
we have also economl economics for for
effect estimation and you see these are
all people from different
different places Microsoft
postdocs from from universities and so
on and also recently we have a new
package started called Pie by stats
where we focus on
uh yeah a bunch of statistical methods
that you might not find in sci-fi or
stats models like conditioning
Independence tests
that that are a bit more
state-of-the-art or stuff like Kyle
diversions estimations for continuous
data
um
which are also not in sci-fi for
instance
and of course you can there could be
your project so if you work on anything
related to cost inference you might
might consider to add your project there
or if it's like a single algorithm where
you think okay it doesn't use a whole
package then maybe one of these other
ones might be a good fit for it so yeah
join join our community
there's the website the documentation of
what you can find here this is the
GitHub organization and yeah the Discord
I don't think you will type in the
Discord link but if you Google it you
will find it every Monday we have like a
public meeting where you can just join
listen in you can ask questions with or
if you have a concrete problem just just
bring it up we're always there to help
um yeah that's that's all then
[Applause]
thank you very much Patrick it's time
for some q a we have quite many
questions on the slider so I start from
them and I also encourage you to vote on
them if you find it interesting and then
maybe we can have some questions from
the audience if there are any so the
first question is how does Auto
assignment in causal relationships work
uh yeah so the
currently we
um it's a bit more heuristic so when we
take a look at um
at this graph for instance what we do is
we first of all have like a default
model for all the for all the root nodes
so the root nodes
the best or like like a good good choice
of distribution if you is if you just
take like the empirical distribution so
you would just take the data itself and
um use this as your distribution and for
the child nodes we typically assume they
follow so-called additive noise models
which means
um this this functional form here is
basically just F of the parents plus
noise and the F if if there's assumption
holds you can find by for instance
taking a regression model that minimizes
the mean squared error so it's like a
classic typical machine learning problem
and and by this we just iterate over all
the nodes and for each node we try to
take the optimal regression model to
describe the node
I hope that whoever asks the question
got the answer there's a quick question
about the availability of the notebook
is there or will it be shared uh yeah
the notebook is you can or you could you
can find it modified version of The
Notebook on the documentation website so
I just modified it a bit for the talk
but otherwise you can find this also on
the on the documentation
um I think documentation is linked in
your uh like right talk description yeah
right all right so
um there's another question about what
kind of input data is supported
numerical categorical temporal
um so the currently supported is uh your
continuous and categorical datum
um
so yeah there there are some tricks to
also support time series data okay it's
not here
um so you you could for instance so
generally we assume that it's IID so we
don't allow temporal connections but
what you could do is you could introduce
artificial like variables and and put
this into your graph to at least have
some some work around for now but time
series support is definitely one of the
most important features that we
hopefully can add in the future but it's
not there yet
sure thank you
uh another popular question is which
readings would you recommend to like
catch up with main knowledge assumptions
and to know which model to use how to
interpret it
um I guess general for causality
um okay so this talk was heavily focused
on so-called graphical causal models
which is like from Pearl's framework I
don't know who's familiar with it but
they're like like two two Frameworks
potential outcome and and graphical
causal models for graphical causal
models the
um guest books like book of Y from Pearl
there's another book which is a bit more
modern elements of causal inference
um which which a bit more based on the
work we are doing
um yeah I guess these these two books
and for the model selection part I don't
think there's a proper literature
it's just uh yeah it's also not not that
well developed yet in the in the
literature as well
um
other question
causal inference is now discipline so
why was Pi y only founded last year
question I mean
um
I mean there's a reason why we founded
it last year is because we open sourced
our library
um and in the same time uh when we talk
with Microsoft we thought it's a good
chance to
maybe go beyond just that one Dubai
library and have like a whole ecosystem
of it because there's nothing like this
in in the causal inference space yet
there are a lot of separate packages
here and there but nothing that that
tries to combine everything so at least
that's the reason why we only did it
last year but I don't know why no one
did it before
sure like I may also mention that I have
some my own answer to that question and
um yeah which you can hear tomorrow in
the talk
and I'm saying that's because the
Slidell got broken so I need to wait for
it to load
uh okay there's another question so can
this kind of causal inference uh be used
interchangeably for explainability of
predictions or forecasting models
what chain okay I guess you cannot ask
contact questions okay so I the way how
it up to the question is so um
you you can use it for explainability
definitely so um when you when you look
at like
okay the main point between or the main
difference between let's say you use a
regression model and you just use
sharply values or something to have like
your typical way of explainability
um then in in regression tasks or in
prediction tasks you don't care about
the causal structure you just throw in
all your variables you define your
Target and you want to have good
accurate predictions and then you want
to explain the model with respect to
that but these explanations are not
necessarily causal so when you think of
of this graph here for instance
um for this red node up here the best
prediction model would take
um this this node here would take this
node basically the so-called Markov
blanket so you would take all these
nodes which are the best best notes to
predict this one but you would also get
like some contribution for instance of
this note here which is strictly
speaking
um independent of of this node so if you
are interested in in causal explanations
you definitely need to model these
causal graphs carefully and use the
under AI models to explain it
and what you can also do is you can
um so this this attribution analysis
here for instance or the the anomaly
detections that you saw earlier is some
kind of an explanation
um because it analyzes what would happen
in a hypothetical world where um this
anomaly did not happen so if if your if
your dynamodb for instance has an
anomaly you would ask a counterfectual
professional okay if it would not happen
and normally would I still observe this
High latency and by this you also have
some kind of an explanation
um in in the causal graph of certain
nodes
which are there are some more questions
but maybe there's somebody want to ask
here
thankful presentation so I have two
questions the first one saw about
assertion points so what is the main
let's say difference between this
framework and the sharp pressure because
I can do the same sharp sharp ever so I
can do let's say approximately the same
in terms of how it come you have or
using sharp libraries I can build the
model and just analyze the outcome for
each feature and the second question so
I got about the model selection but uh
is it a way to have to build this causal
graph or do I need to
satisfy I mean create it manually and if
there is a way to build it automatically
how that's a short story how do we do it
thanks okay so the the first one
regarding you mean ShopRite the chef
yeah
um so this this is a point I
um mentioned earlier so you can use Chef
for instance to describe each model
individually here but you um it does
make sense if you
um I mean Shep is just focusing on
explaining whatever model you you train
there and this model that you put in
there doesn't necessarily need to be
causal but if it's causal then it it
could make sense to use Shep there as
well so for instance if you just use a
model that uses these two nodes to
predict your red node here then and it's
it's a causal model and then if you ship
then you get a also a good causal
explanation for your for your Target
values but if you just care about care
about predictions you might would also
include this yellow note here
um and then the shape explanation would
not make sense with respect to to to the
causal explanation just think of it um
if you would change the the yellow note
here it would not impact your parent
node the the call Direction only goes in
the other other way so whatever
statements you get from from Shep there
would not make sense with respect to the
to the causal directions and the second
thing was what was it about building
this graph in the first place yeah
um yeah this is this of course the
hardest hardest problem and so there are
ways to infer this from data
um using for instance Independence tests
so for instance you know that these two
nodes have to be statistically
independent so you know there's no
connection you know that this node needs
to be
um
oh needs to be dependent with its
parents and these two nodes become
conditionally dependent if you condition
on this so okay long story short there
are some statistical methods to to also
infer this graph and um this is this is
one way how you could do it but um at
least in practice they don't work that
well so it's it's better if you have
domain knowledge that that builds us for
you
hmm
yeah I thank you for your talk first of
all I have one question can you
interface this already with libraries
like torch
um or the Deep learning stuff so to say
uh yeah so we we try to have it very
modular
um
so the okay let me switch over here
so we have some certain interface that
needs to be fulfilled so for instance if
you use an additive noise model then you
have your typical psychic learn
interface you have a fit and predict
method and
you could Implement a deep new network
whatever fancy structure you have there
that just implements fit and predict and
then you can just plug it in as possible
and of course everything that
scikit-learn supports is already
possible out of the box and we also have
some experimental uh features where we
replace that whole thing with a with a
stable diffusion model which which is a
bit more modern
um way of modeling stuff so um yeah okay
this is It's modular you can plug it in
yeah
hmm
question
yeah thanks for the talk and how much
data do you need to actually build a
useful graph
yeah the I mean that's like order of
magnitude yeah I mean the classical
machine learning professional much data
you need um
it's it yeah I guess it depends so if
you have like in in this case for
instance we know it's very nicely linear
right so a few data points like
2030 is probably enough to learn a
linear model
um but as soon as becomes more complex
you need more data and then in
particular
um in here in this case we not only have
the regression problem we also have the
problem of modeling the causal
mechanisms which means we also have this
this noise part in here
um so you need actually a bit more data
than you would need in typical
regression tasks to also have a good
approximation of this noise
um
but yeah I would say roughly the same as
if you have any kind of regression
problem
um
same amount of data although here you
have multiple regression problems right
for each node there's a separate one so
yeah it's I cannot give I guess a good
good amount there but
would say 50 when it's linear and
probably thousands if it's non-linear
thanks
okay I
we
unless there's somebody who would like
to ask
a question no so thank you very much
Patrick please give another round of
applause
thank you